sex toys most of them are designed to
help women achieve orgasm and the idea
that you could openly sell things that
help women achieve orgasm is pretty new
hi i'm nick gillespie with reason TV and
today we're talking with Phil Harvey
he's an entrepreneur he's a
philanthropist and he's also the author
of the new novel Showtime Phil thanks
for talking to us I player you are also
a sometime donor to Reason Foundation
the nonprofit that publishes reason.com
and reason TV so thank you for that
we've got that out of the way yes we do
now Showtime your novel is a take on
reality TV and it has seven people who
have to live on an island in the middle
of Lake Superior as winter approaches
the winners emerge and get four hundred
thousand dollars it's a dark interesting
darkly comic take on reality TV as well
as both a world in which people are have
to do things or feel they have to do
things for money as well as the greed
and power trips of well-placed
individuals what brought you to write
this book well I've always been
interested in violence as entertainment
something that we have a great deal of
in American and most other cultures I
think we have a bit more of an addiction
to it in the United States them than
many other countries and the idea that
violence is entertainment might go
beyond a chance of death as in NASCAR
racing or professional football which
has gotten quite dangerous now to a
point where the producers of a reality
show would actually hope for a fatality
and where the audience would be kind of
sitting on the edge of their seats
hoping for something perhaps close to a
death it seemed to me to be an
intriguing proposition and interesting
hypothesis are you a critic of violence
and sexuality and popular culture do you
see that as dissent desensitizing or
dehumanizing people
no I'm certainly not a critic of
violence or sexuality and literature or
entertainment the and i'm not i'm not
either a critic or a fan of reality
shows except that they're all obviously
rehearsed and therefore hypocritical and
i don't particularly enjoy watching them
and therefore writing something that is
a dark parody of a reality TV was a
pleasure for me to take on but we need
violence and sexuality and our
entertainment i think human beings are
descended from people who had to deal
with violence to survive and simulated
or possible violence or even as I point
out in the book from time to time little
wars of which I'm afraid we've had too
many now in the United States are
satisfying to people and therefore in
democracies to their to their political
leaders violence worldwide is going down
which which is something of a surprise
to a lot of people but the chances of
anyone dying violently at the hands of
another human being are less today than
they ever have been in the history of
humankind so we're becoming a less
violent species at the but we need we
need it for sublimation and and also sex
as well write our representations of sex
also I mean you have been you're the
founder and president of the Adam and
Eve catalogue leading adult products do
you see now say starting from the the
80s to now are we in a better age where
people understand that fantasy violence
and fantasies sexuality provides a
positive social roller can or are we
actually moving backwards towards more
repression of expression I would say in
general we're not moving backward to
more repression of speech except at
Harvard where and and other private
universities where speech codes have
become absolutely ridiculous and
if you happen to be a student at one of
those universities or colleges your
speech is more curtail than it is
anywhere else I I think in in the United
States today but generally we're
certainly not going back to the days
when Lady Chatterley's Lover could be
declared illegal we're not going back to
the days where Ulysses could be banned
in in general but how much of that is
changing social mores and how much that
is technological change that just allows
people to rat around RS forms of
censorship it's change in sexual mores i
think that the american society clearly
is much more open and receptive to the
idea of good sex the discussion of sex
in most cultures for centuries past has
all been about bad sex what you
shouldn't do what you can't do sex toys
most of them are designed to help women
achieve orgasm and the idea that you
could openly sell things that help women
achieve orgasm is pretty new yeah but it
is now widely widely accepted and i
think that the revolution in women's
views about their own sexuality and
their right if you will to enjoy a full
sexual life is relatively new and i
think all of that is is very positive
what was the trigger on that you know
and I hate to say what pulled the
trigger on the female orgasm but I mean
you know female sexuality has always
been you know feared by mail society and
patriarchy and whatnot as a
destabilizing factor it's true that the
West broadly speaking embraced female
sexuality is a fact of life and not a
bad thing sometime in the past 30 40
maybe 50 years what what changed that I
don't know it made it may simply be
the emergence of anatomy I mean men have
tried for millennia not only centuries
to suppress female sexuality the early
Christians were absolute bears about it
calling intercourse disgusting and
filthy and of course in many
conservative Muslim societies today the
men are so afraid of sex that they cover
women from head to toe lest they be
reminded sex is a very powerful part of
human existence otherwise we wouldn't be
here while you're fighting off the Lions
on the saber-toothed Tigers you've got
to have a pretty strong sex drive to
procreate and our ancestors did and
we're left with a very very powerful
sexuality which a great many people are
afraid of they're afraid of their own
sexuality but sooner or later and as
society has become more tolerant of
different kinds of people and different
attitudes and that's a worldwide trend
it has also made it possible for women
to say and for men to say about women
that they're entitled to sexual pleasure
and fulfillment just as just as men are
you know one of the things that's
interesting about your work and your
kind of portfolio of your work is so
you've got the novel you've got that's
just out you've written other books in
the past that talk about for instance
the government versus erotica which was
a bachelors your battles against the
federal and state government
prosecutions related to the Adam and Eve
kind of like dkt international another
major business that you do you provide
low-cost voluntary family planning to
developing nations in this you are also
routing around government censorship and
government repression in many ways can
you talk a little bit about your efforts
there and how that fits in with your
other interests well promoting birth
control family planning and developing
countries has been a career interest of
mine either because of great good luck
or because both my organization dkt and
a number of others have been
fairly effective in delivering the goods
we've seen great success worldwide and
what does that mean what's his great
success great success means that from a
relatively small fraction of sexually
active couples using birth control in
mid-century or even in 1970 today sixty
percent of all cohabiting couples in the
world are using some form of modern
birth control a huge huge difference and
birth rates have fallen accordingly the
number of children born by the average
woman in the world has fallen from an
average of five just 20 or 30 years ago
22 in a fraction and what's important
about I do that that that represents a
choice I mean we're not taught you you
are very much in opposition to something
like the Chinese one-child policy or
anything like that what you're talking
about here is an exercise of choice that
leads to a change in the birth rate
absolutely and indeed to me whether it
leads to a change in the birth rate or
not isn't terribly important I think it
is probably a good thing that people are
choosing to have fewer fewer children
today because one of the reasons is that
they're the children they do have are
much more likely to live the condition
of families around the world and babies
while still much improvement is needed
are much better today than they were 20
or 30 years ago but the main thing to me
in making birth control easily
conveniently and openly available around
the world which requires some pushing
against sensors and part of what we do
is to keep pushing the edge of the
envelope on what success acceptable in
television advertising for example in in
the Philippines or Vietnam or India most
of which tend to be more liberal in this
respect in the United States does tend
to contribute to a liberalizing trend
visa vie
family planning but the main thing is
that people have that choice they can
decide how many children to have it's a
basic issue of freedom and my impression
is that once women have started making
those choices in deciding when to get
pregnant when to bear children there's
no going back you're not going to see
birth rates shoot up again around the
world in my opinion we're probably going
to top out at about 9 million people and
then start to shrink well you know in
your in your professional life or in
your in your day job I guess day jobs
you're very goal-oriented and your your
products and your activity have a
certain message I know you've said that
you don't particularly care for a
didactic fiction that novels that have a
point or an ax to grind tend to be
uninteresting but to bring it back to
show time what is what is a takeaway and
does it revolve around a kind of idea of
self control or empowerment or what what
is the ultimate message that you want
people to take away from reading
Showtime well I don't particularly want
them to take away a message I want them
to enjoy reading the book to get into a
different world in a different place and
have fun doing it but that said a
message that I focused on when writing
it is this idea of violence as
entertainment this idea that people
increasingly including the government
are going to be pulling the strings of
entertainment in such a way as to
provide vicarious violence to very large
numbers of people and that we will
always have a few and maybe more than a
few gladiator equivalence and indeed the
people in the book are in a sense
gladiator equivalence risking their
lives the participants in Hunger Games
are even more literally
gladiators because many of them have to
die whereas in my book it isn't an
absolute essential component but of
course that's part of the book to me the
intellectually interesting part of this
is the fact that we crave violence if it
bleeds it leads we all know that you
can't get attention by broadcasting good
news and the more violence the more
violent the news is the more likely it
is to be to be watched and build ratings
there is something inherent in humans
that finds violence interesting
compelling and to some extent necessary
the logical end of that is going to be
violence either in the form of little
wars in the form of television programs
that include the possibility at least of
real violence as some of our
entertainment already does or other
vicarious ways of meeting this need
which we're always going to have until
we get to genetic manipulation of human
beings which is another subject for
another time yes and what a dull world
that will be yes all the will yes well
the novel the book is Showtime the
author is Phil Harvey who also is in
charge of the Adam and Eve catalog and
dkt international Phil thanks for
talking to us my pleasure for reason TV
I'm Nicholas
you